minutes pour commenter un tweet dont
vous dirai peut-être qu'il est
anecdotique ou insignifiants mais qui
nous a semblé intéressant quand même la
cinéaste agnès varda est décédé c'était
la semaine dernière et il ya une
association qui s'appelle osez le
féminisme dont le nom dit bien quel est
l'objet social qui a tout et agnès varda
nous quitte mais nous laisse de grands
films féministes jusqu'à présent rien
d'extraordinaire et cette association
ajoute à voir et à revoir
pour lui rendre fait mage et oui fait
maj plutôt comme âge parce que hommage
ce serait uniquement pour les hommes
alors pour tourner à un plateau
paritaire aujourd'hui donc on est ravis
on en profite
alexandra saviana est ce que vous
aimeriez le plus tard possible qu'on
vous rendre un jour fait mal écoutez ce
tweet et comme vous l'avez dit
insignifiance c'est certes le mot n'est
pas heureux et je vais pas être la
première à demander à ce qu'on me rendre
ces maj je voulais à vous mais c'est
c'est tout simplement une provocation
d'une association qui veut faire parler
de son combat et je pense que c'est une
tempête dans un verre d'eau ça vaut pas
une discussion de débat mais il ya pas
que ça quand même parce que c'est ça va
avec l'écriture inclusive ça va avec la
féminisation des dd non vous savez bien
que c'est un mouvement général c'est
pour ça qu'on s'est permis de passer
quelques minutes mais je comprends mais
c'est tout à fait légitime et l'écriture
inclusive et est une vraie question en
elle même mais je pense pas que fait ma
jeu corresponde à vraiment à l'écriture
inclusive c'est une fantaisie
visiblement de quelqu'un qui était très
triste de la mort d'agnès varda et qui a
donc décidé de rappeler que c'était une
auteure féministe alors il ya un
linguiste professeur des universités qui
a fait une tribune assez sévère dans le
figaro vox sur 7 sur ce twitt en disant
notamment d'un usage le mot hommage ne
fait pas référence à l'homme ce pseudo
féminisme invendus sexisme patrick lozès
d'accord non mais on est dans une époque
se reprend ce que vous dites et des
tempêtes dans un verre d'eau pour faire
du buzz pour faire parler de soi même
c'est terrible sans changer de sujet
mais c'est la même chose
la pièce de théâtre qui devait avoir
lieu à la sorbonne et parce que les des
acteurs avec des masques noirs a été
interdite parce qu'il ya un groupuscule
qui défend les noirs qui a dit que
c'était du racisme
on marche sur la tête quoi s'est il ya
un moment donné moi je comprends les
combats sociaux je suis à fond pour le
féminisme etc
il faut pas ridiculiser des combats par
des petites choses il ya des choses je
veux dire moi qu'on parle des combats
sur le féminisme avec les femmes
migrantes enceinte qui arrive qu'ils
sont seuls qui sont à la rue et on a un
des centaines de femmes chaque soir qui
dorment dans la rue avec leur gamin
c'est un vrai problème là là il ya
vraiment un live ya vraiment un problème
et c'est ce même jean cela mauvaise plus
activement dans cette même tribune
il l'est il dit le vrai féminisme ne
consiste pas inventé les interprétations
symbolique mais s attaquer aux
injustices pourquoi ne pas s'en prendre
à la misogynie réel que représente le
voile islamique par exemple céline pina
ce taux est ce que ce sont un peu des
diversions ce genre de deux tweets je
pense que pour les gens qui les font ils
peuvent y croire profondément il ya des
gens qui pense profondément que si on
féminise les noms on rendra leur place
aux femmes et il ne croit vraiment donc
mais moi ce qui me semble quand même
extrêmement dangereux c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de créer
des coupures des abîmes des césures est
donc une femme ne pourrait pas rendre
hommage ou quand une femme meurt lui
rendre hommage ce serait insultant c'est
quand même particulièrement stupide ça
me rappelle les débats en disant il
faudrait qu'ils étendent % de femmes à
l'assemblée nationale mais imaginez que
c'est 50 % de femmes se soient tout
madame le pen par exemple ont une autre
peu importe mais j'allais dire ce qui
compte c'est les idées ce qui compte
c'est ce que ce que font les gens c'est
ce qu'ils sont or là on en arrive les
mêmes d'ailleurs qui
vous se battre sur la thème de fées
mages sont souvent les mêmes qui n'ont
pas d'attitude universaliste sont
souvent les mêmes qui vont expliquer qu'
un féminisme blanc et qui a un féminisme
intersectionnelle sont les mêmes en gros
c'est on se dit féministe mais la seule
chose qu'on défend c'est le port du
voile et l'appartenance ethnique
voilà c'est on est vraiment très très
loin de l'émancipation
je me permets juste pour l'adisq pour la
définition de l'intersexualité c'est
quand même une
une notion qui ne se limite pas qu'aux
voile islamique et c'est une femme noire
va avoir plus de on va dire
discrimination qu une femme blanche
parce qu'elle allait de la
discrimination du fait d'être une femme
et du fait d'être noir donc mais après
sur le sur la façon dont ça se défend
c'est pour ça que je disais qu'il y
avait des liens ethniques c'est par
exemple de dire si une femme noire se
fait violer par un blanc il faut qu'elle
porte plainte c'est très important si
elle se fait violer par un noir à ce
moment là il faut qu'elles se taisent
parce que le combat noire est plus
important que le combat féministe donc
cesser
elle porte des logiques qui sont
extrêmement compliqué à défendre et qui
sont absolument pas féministe et souvent
ils ne récupèrent pas quand vous vous
dites dans un mouvement vous appartenez
à son histoire par exemple si vous vous
dites féministe vous savez que la femme
elle a lutté pour avoir la maîtrise de
son corps jusqu'à lives et j'ai
d'ailleurs la maîtrise de sa sexualité
et qu'elles luttent aussi pour
socialement être un être politique
autrement dit avoir le droit de vote les
mêmes droits et c'est souvent ces
féministes la évacue complètement ces
questions là donc moi ce qui me gêne un
petit peu c'est que on nous alors qu'il
ya de vrais problèmes comme l'excision
comme effectivement le voile comme
même les problèmes de salaires
différents on va s'exciter sur des mots
sur du vocabulaire
on va expliquer finalement donc quand
une femme meurt il faut lui rendre
hommage et si c'est un homme il lui rend
fait majou hommage
et si c'est un homme et que c'est une
femme qui lui rend hommage elle doit lui
rendre fait mal
enfin si un transsexuel on fait quoi
elle lui donne trans mages ça devient
vraiment délirant stupide et je crois
qu'on est vraiment je crois qu'il y
avait un truc c'était les théories de la
gen y rit ben oui on est avec des gens
qui geignent en permanence et ses passes
à se battre c'est pas ça faire avancer
l'émancipation aux internautes sont
assez d'accord avec vous même
complètement d'accord avec vous quand on
leur demande faut-il rendre fait match
plutôt comme âge 94% répondants alors
comme vous avez l'air assez d'accord moi
j'ai deux petites questions à vous poser
est ce que l'expression alors d'accéder
gagner peut-être que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être dit
non mais il faut métiers du débat mais
je vais être rapide jeu je pense que
évidemment c'est plus que discutable et
vous l'avez dit même le terme même
dommage en réalité c'est je dire est en
capacité de se soumettre face à
quelqu'un donc le média puis y'a pas de
sexualité dans l'utilisation du terme et
d'une certaine s'il y en avait une elle
serait même inverse à l'idée qu'on se
fait de la discrimination de ce terme
donc je pense que c'est effectivement
une simple provocation c'est pas
forcément utile je crois dans le débat
mais ne soyons pas non plus dans des
généralisations c'est à dire que cette
association là comme d'autres
quelques fois fait preuve de provocation
j'entends bras dans la tribune du figaro
box qu'on revient sur
la nécessité de ne pas toucher aux mots
moi je me félicite que l'académie
française et enfin décider ce qui n'est
pas la même chose comme hd fait mal mais
de fait mise énorme et on qu'on peut pas
y voilà attention exactement ces autres
exemples vivante elle est là pour
défendre le français je suis d'accord je
parlais justement de la tribune qui lie
les deux qu'ils disent c'est pas bien de
parler de fait mal et d'ailleurs on ne
devrait pas changer la langue je suis
totalement d'accord avec vous je dis ce
n'est pas bien de parler de fait mal ça
me semble être une mauvaise idée
par contre ne résumons pas l'ensemble
enfin nous n'en profitons pas pour
remettre en cause vincent descombes
défendre la langue française la langue
dans au
c'est à dire qu'en fait ce devrait être
des choses qui devraient se répandre
d'elle-même d'ailleurs on voit quand le
terme sonne bien
quand il a du sens finalement la
féminisation entre guillemets prend
quand on en a moins
bah ça ne prends pas mes jeux comme je
dis toujours il vaut mieux avoir
beaucoup de femmes à des postes de
pouvoir que féminiser les titres de
pouvoir est ce que l'expression
déclaration des droits de l'homme ça
vous choque ou pas mais mais ça va on
parle tous bien le français
c'est l'homme c'est l'homme c'est pas
l'homme et la femme
cc c'est l'os et le genre humain c'est
le genre humain c'est l'espèce humaine
est d'accord avec vous mais je pose la
question quand même parce qu'il ya des
gens qui disent faut dire les droits
humains faut plus dire des droits de
l'homme et à ce moment là mais cela tue
très vite des trois doses de la femme et
des transsexuels et des unijambistes y
voilà mais dans la vie on n'a jamais dit
qu'elle était parfaite
elles permettent d'arrêter de perdre du
temps à des bêtises pour justement aller
au coeur des choses
acceptons les conventions elles servent
à ça alors acceptons les conventions ça
me va c'est bien de temps en temps c'est
beaucoup à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission très bon week
end j'aurais le plaisir de vous
retrouver lundi prochain pour un nouveau
point de vue
[Musique]